[Music]
emu is the secret Immortal ruler of the
entire world and the single most
mysterious character in all of One Piece
but while the info we have about emu
right now is limited in this video I
will talk about four key pieces of
information that Oda already revealed
and that spoiled the truth about emu
even before it's all confirmed
officially now you're going to think
that point number four is crazy at first
but trust me once you hear it you're
going to think it was obvious so let's
get into it jumping right into Point
number one immortality IM or IMU Sama is
almost certainly an immortal being who
has been ruling the world from the
shadows for over 800 years ever since
the void Century in fact he is
speculated to be one of the 20 original
founders of the world government Saint
emu of the nerona family Ivanov believes
that the current emu and the ancient U
are the same person and that this
person's life was likely extended using
the opop noi and its perennial youth
operation if this Theory turns out to be
correct then the current ruler of the
world IMU Sama personally witnessed and
shaped the events of the Void Century he
must have seen the ancient Kingdom with
his own eyes he must have known Joy boy
and the other important figures from the
past personally and so on covering the
truth about emu is crucial for solving
the mysteries of the ancient Kingdom the
void Century the one piece treasure and
of course the Declan speaking of the
Declan this brings me to the second key
piece of information the fact that 800
years ago emu was betrayed by Lily
nefari the ancient ruler of alabaster
and emu knew that he was betrayed the
moment he learned that Lily's full name
was actually Lily D nefari even though
the former queen of alabasta nefatari
Lily was supposed to have left marijua
and returned to alabasta she never
actually made it back she completely
disappeared from history and her place
as ruler of alabasta was taken over by
her younger brother so the the nefari
family did continue to rule the country
but not through Lily Lily vanished as if
she had been deliberately erased from
history when Cobra asks the five Elders
what happened to Lily they simply say
that they don't know according to the
records Lily did not agreed to become a
Celestial Dragon and she did not pledge
her sword to the empty Throne that is
why there are only 19 swords around the
throne itself instead of 20 but the
specifics have been lost to time and so
the Goro simply assumed that Lily went
home Cobra then follows up by asking
what is the D all five Elders are
shocked by this question and they ask
why Cobra would ask such a thing Cobra
reveals that even though Lily never came
back to alabasta she did leave a brief
800-year-old letter behind this letter
has been passed on from ruler to ruler
within the nefatari family from the time
of the Void century and that is the
moment in which emu decides to publicly
reveal himself to COBRA which shocks the
Goro IMU Sama speaks the word Lily then
walks up to the empty throne and sits on
top of it IMU says D is the moner of our
ancient enemy in recent times it cropped
up more frequently however it is nothing
but a faint Echo those who carry the
name do not even know its true meaning
this confirms that the Declan are
enemies of the Gods in other words the
enemies of the world Nobles which is
something that we've heard before and we
know that modern Declan members like
Luffy don't really know what the D
actually represents so emu is right on
that point but even though emu tries to
downplay the significance of this
initial it is clear that the D is
troubling to him I guess you can say
that emu can't handle the D now do me a
big favor and leave a like on this video
to make up for all the people who are
going to leave a dislike after that
terrible joke anyway emu says that all
of this is Lily's fault without Lily's
blunder Pirates would not be chasing the
poneglyphs and those vexing relics would
never have been scattered all over the
world it seems that Lily nefari made
some kind of mistakes that allowed the
release of the poneglyphs and so instead
of them being hidden away under strict
government control they were released
into the world where they could be read
and then the information could be used
to harm the world government emu always
suspected that maybe Lily didn't just
make a terrible mistake maybe she
allowed the poneglyph to escape world
government control on purpose because
she was actually a traitor after all the
information on these poneglyphs
represents a huge danger to the world
government so releasing them into the
world on purpose means that you want to
bring the world government down it seems
that Lily tried to play it off as some
sort of mistake or accident but emu
isn't buying it and in order to confirm
his suspicions he demands to know what
was in Lily's letter how did Lily sign
the letter was it simply as Queen Lily
of the house nefatari or was there
something else in her name Cobra who is
is already aware at this point that he
is basically a dead man decides to just
tell the truth the letter written by
alabaster's ancient ruler was signed by
Queen nefari D lily as we later learn
Lily's letter said the poneglyphs must
be protected fly the flag that Heralds
the world's eventual Dawn but as soon as
emu heard the initial D the time for
talking immediately ended and a sharp
arrow-shaped tail rushed towards Cobra
and pierced through him the tail and U's
trans formation into a dark giant
monster is directly related to his
incredible devil fruit power and that is
the key piece of information number
three emu's devil fruit the big reveal
of emu's powers came in chapter
1085 and in many ways his devil fruit
appeared to be the dark counterpart of
Luffy's naika fruit just like NAA emu's
devil fruit seems to give its user the
ability to instantly turn into a giant
cartoonish creature a creature that can
perform such ridiculous Feats as
creating a giant mouth and swallowing
sabo's Flame without taking any damage
Yu also appears to control a long black
arrow that can be used to attack and
Pierce his opponents from a distance and
this Arrow could actually be an
arrow-shaped tail like the ones that
Devils often have in cartoons and
especially in those old rubber hose
cartoons that Na's own powers are based
on but although both devil fruits seem
to allow its user to transform in
cartoonish ways and do ridiculous things
that shouldn't even be possible outside
of cartoons these two devil fruits are
not the same instead these powers could
be seen as the perfect counterparts to
each other Luffy's Awakening turns his
hair and much of his clothing white he
becomes a creature known as the son God
and he is set to bring freedom and joy
to everyone around him on the other hand
emu is known for being dressed in all
black and his devil fruit power turns
him into a dark monster while Joy boy is
a warrior of Liberation who brings
laughter and joy and who promises to
reveal the truth about the world and to
liberate everyone from oppression emu
oppresses the world from the Shadows
hides the truth in dark Ness erases
history and uses fear and violence to
force everyone to conform to his rule
emu is essentially the dark counterpart
of Luffy and his devil fruit is like the
antia one thing that occurred to me and
that was also mentioned by other
YouTubers like arur from the library of
aara was the possibility that if NAA has
the power to turn imagination into
reality and essentially make dreams come
true then maybe emu's anti-a power is to
bring someone's worst fears and
Nightmares into reality now that would
be an incredible op devil fruit power
that is absolutely perfect for a villain
the fourth and final key point about emu
comes when we finally have emu speak for
the first time in chapter
1085 now unfortunately I don't speak
Japanese and the intricacies of emu's
speech patterns can only be fully
understood by someone who does speak
Japanese thankfully the one piece
Community has the legendary Ur from the
library of aara and he was able to fill
us in on all the specifics of emu's
speech link to AR 's video is in the
description by the way if one piece
content interests you at all you should
definitely be subscribed to arur now the
first piece of information is that emu
doesn't really speak in a highly
distinguished and refined way instead
the ruler of the entire world speaks
rather casually he does use some very
old and outdated words and expressions
but that makes sense if we assume that
emu is really an immortal being who has
been around for like 800 years but
here's the more interesting thing emu
speaks about himself in the third person
in a pretty childish way and arur
describes it as almost coming off like a
kid trying to sound edgy and cool emu is
also prone to temper tantrums and he
instantly attacks king cobra as soon as
he hears that Lily had the initial D
even though he may have been able to get
more information out of Cobra if he had
been more patient now of course we know
that emu isn't a literal child because
he's an 800-year-old immortal being but
he might have become immortal while he
was still a child making him something
like an eternal child with special
powers I'm magical boy who wouldn't grow
up wait wait doesn't that sound kind of
familiar okay before you call me insane
and dislike the video give me just a few
minutes to convince you that the
character of U was actually inspired by
none other than Peter Pan when I say
Peter Pan you probably thinking of the
Disney version of the character but the
original Peter Pan from the novel was
actually a lot darker and the draft
versions of the original story that were
uncovered after the author's death were
even darker still in fact at one point
Peter Pan was apparently going to be the
main villain of the story besides the
fact that both pan and emu may be
Eternal children who never grew up and
besides the fact that emu and pan both
have magical powers there are other
similarities between the two emu is
famously fond of his secret garden also
known as the room of flowers and of
butterflies these butterflies are often
used to symbolize him in the Manga and
Anime Peter Pan is also associated with
Wilderness and nature and he hangs out
with fairies like Tinkerbell fairies who
have wings like butter but flies Peter
Pan is known for randomly forgetting
things which is associated with his
magical immortality and residing in
Neverland The Lost Boys the group of
Orphans who live in Neverland and who
are led by pan eventually forget how
they got to Neverland and that there's
an outside world in the first place emu
is not known for losing his own memory
but he is known for trying to erase
things from history so essentially he's
trying to erase the collective memory of
humanity he basically wants Humanity to
become like The Lost Boys to forget how
the world government even came into
being in the first place and to forget
that there was ever a World outside of
the World Government after all if you
never even consider an alternative to
the current system because you don't
know that an alternative ever existed
you are much less likely to rebel
against this system oh and do you
remember who just happened to be Peter
Pan's enemies in the story you know the
group of people who are waging a
constant war against Peter Pan and the
lost boys that's right it's literally
Pirates but why would one of the main
villains of One Piece be based on a
Disney hero like Peter Pan well for a
long time people have speculated that
Peter Pan is a lot more Sinister than we
realize in fact he is actually the
villain of the story even in Canon
material it is implied that he kidnaps
The Lost Boys after they wander away
from their parents in a public park and
then he takes them to Neverland where
they forget their past lives and just
assume that they are orphans in the
books he is even implied to kill off the
lost boys when they get get too old Yes
you heard that right unlike pan The Lost
Boys actually age in Neverland but the
reason why they're all still kids is
because pan kills them when they become
too old some even believe that Captain
Hook and the Pirates are actually former
lost boys who rebelled against pan and
got away before he could kill them which
is why they were able to grow into
adults in the first place so Peter Pan
is not actually a friendly Kid looking
for some friends despite acting like an
edgy child he is actually an ancient and
Sinister being who like the Pied Piper
abducts children and then murders them
when he's done playing with them some
even believe that Peter Pan was never
human at all and that he is actually a
demon who takes on a human form to trick
children into following him into
Neverland as I said earlier in rough
drafts of the story Peter Pan was
supposed to be the main villain and he
was apparently referred to as a demon
Boy by the author himself and who do we
know with demonic powers in one piece
Saturn the other GTO and of course emu
Peter Pan himself was partially inspired
by the Greek god Pan the god of
wilderness who was known for instilling
fear and panic into humans who wander
into his domain in fact the very word
panic comes from pan because anyone who
entered his neck of the woods would hear
his cries and instantly become terrified
again this is not too far from emu who
also loves nature and likes to tend to
his garden and who instills fear into
all of humanity through his position as
the ruler of the world government if
you're interested in this topic of Peter
Pan being a villain I will link a video
down in the description that goes in
depth into all the lore but if emu
really is a dark Peter Pan type
character then what does this mean for
our story for one it means that emu's
real appearance might be very childlike
which means that he could actually have
already shown himself in the story but
we just don't realize it yet he may have
already appeared as some random child
that Luffy and the straw hats came
across in the story and we would never
know it because we wouldn't expect that
an innocent looking child was actually
the main villain of the story the idea
that Luffy and the straw hats may have
already met emu without knowing it is
intriguing but whether or not that
actually happened I think that emu
definitely knew the original Joy boy
personally actually I think Joy boy may
have been a lost boy who was at one
point allied with emu but then decided
to turn against him and become a pirate
from the whole story of Lily we already
know that some of U's allies ended up
betraying him because they found out
that his ultimate plan was evil evil and
these are the people who eventually
formed the D Clan just like Lily became
a part of the D Clan when she turned
against emu interestingly enough the
story of Peter Pan also has a character
named Lily more specifically her name is
Tiger Lily and in the story she is in
love with pan so what if during the void
Century emu Joy boy and Lily along with
many others teamed up to overthrow The
lunarians Who at that time lived at top
the red line and were seen as gods among
men maybe the 20 kingdoms and their
allies were initially fighting to
overthrow an oppressive regime this
would explain why emu doesn't talk like
a royal he started out as a rebel a
commoner but then once the war was won
former allies emu and joy boy came to
very different conclusions about what to
do next Joy boy Lily and their allies
wanted freedom and equality for all the
kingdoms and races but emu believed that
the only way to preserve peace and order
was to establish a new dictatorial
regime the the regime that we know today
as the world government Joy boy Lily and
the others who disagreed with emu
decided to rebel against him they became
Pirates and they formed the D Clan but
emu was Stronger probably due in part to
his overpowered demonic devil fruit and
in the end emu and the world government
won if emu is the Peter Pan in this
story then he would have been the
captain the leader of the Lost Boys he
literally made them who they are he made
Joy boy and he was also the one who
ultimately destroyed him but thanks to
Lily the hope of the Pirates and the
Declan lived on until one day Joy boy
returned in the form of Monkey D Luffy
so what do you think is my theory that
emu's character may be based on an evil
version of Peter Pan beginning to sound
convincing to you let me know down below
if you're looking for another intriguing
one piece video to watch next check out
my video on why I think Luffy's devil
fruit has a second Awakening link on
screen and in the
description